today at American Express Studios we're
talking about to cutting-edge
destinations that will make you want to
buy a one-way to first up Singapore a
city that feels like it's already in the
future sure they have old temples but
they also have citywide Wi-Fi Bitcoin
ATMs and crazy architecture the subway
is one of the fastest I've ever seen and
there's a connected infrastructure that
diverts traffic from congested areas and
the tech you can buy 3d printers VR
headsets mobile phone projectors it's
crazy town now in the future we might be
sending you to city that has flying cars
but Tokyo has the next best thing a
magnetic levitation train and robots
that wander Museum and if all that tires
you out head to a restaurant that will
let you order off of your tablet and
receive your food be a conveyor belt and
if you're still on the fence about
checking these places out just think
these two cities have probably come more
futuristic than they were at the
beginning of this episode because
science that's why got a tech loving
travel buddy tag them in the comments to
give them a little inspiration for their
next trip